[Musique]
il y a des rues plus animées la nuit que
la journée et pourtant c'est là que se
rend
Fabrice ça va ou quoi la forme alors
allez for en forme en forme plaisir on
fait tranquille un groupe de passionnés
de sport de combat s'apprête à organiser
une manifestation pas comme les autres
visé cet endroit pour pour donner un
aspect un autre aspect à la boxe plus en
mode Chud dans un établissement un
établissement de nuit pour cibler notre
clientèle comme message ben que à
travers le sport on peut on peut se
produire dans différents endroits et
puis ça peut ouvrir des perspectives de
carrière on a nos petits jeunes qui sont
intéressés justement par ce concept donc
ils veulent intégrer il veent justement
ils veulent intégrer la la team pour
pour accéder à ce concept là ils aiment
bien s'amuser en boîte de nuit mais ils
veulent montrer aussi qu'il y a le côté
sportif il y a pas que boîte de nuit
pour danser donc voilà un consat puni
comme vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dit et pour faire le spectacle des
jeunes combattants réignonnés plein
d'espoir pour leur discipline et pour
je suis déjà combattant en Pancras c'est
en MMA ouais mais comme m'était dit
c'est mon frérot donc je lui donne un
coup de main à représenter un peu son
association et parfois faut faire un peu
confiance aux associations quand même
voilà on n pas le choix on est dedans on
aime le sport on fait confiance et après
c'est à eux de mettre à nous en l' quoi
enfin g les gens comprennent que c'est
avant tout le sport déjà avant tout le
sport c'est pas on n'est pas des bagarux
de rue on n'est pas non c'est pas du
tout ça on est des sportifs on a envie
de monter au plus haut niveau et du coup
on compte sur beaucoup de gens beaucoup
d'épaules surtout beaucoup
d'encouragement pour suivre nous quoi en
tant que
boxeur rien d'original pour cette
formule qui existe déjà dans le monde
entier dans un lieu atypique le sport
devient noble c'est avant tout du sport
donc c'est pas du combat c'est pas c'est
pas je justement pour donner le bon
exemple aux jeunes qui viennent ici qui
viennent en discothèque au lieu d'aller
se taper dessus dehors bah il devrai
quand même s'inscrire dans dans un sport
de combat et puis apprendre aussi à être
plus plus plus digne avoir plus de
respect donc c'est ça un peu les bases
du sport et c'est un peu une prévention
donc ici qu'on fait pour cette soirée
adapter la formule et prouver que le
sport peut faire du bien quel que soit
son lieu de pratique sera le défi du 6
février
[Musique]
prochain